[Music]
Maebh review it's spooky time spooky
time
it's October everybody and you know what
that means
every year on meme review it's spooky
time the favorite time of year where we
review spooky memes can we get some
really creepy music some really Shane
Dawson montage documentary style music
to really set the tone of this main
review and let's review some freaking
creepy spooky spooky memes our first
spooky meme don't get too spooked out
now all right we got Mickey Mouse hey
what is he doing is it gonna take pizza
that would be spooky [ __ ] but ah
he stole the children hey stop
I am so spooked out how am I going to
trust Mickey Mouse from now on I thought
he was one of the good guys
Mickey Mouse confirmed sociopath time
for spooky meme number two everyone we
have an announcement to make so I just
got the chills we don't play around here
on spooky month on meme review to him
yeah I masturbate upload spooky memes
Gucci gang have you guys thumbs up this
video yet make sure you do otherwise I
bet you or you have your flesh and skin
exposed what are you some kind of loser
I bet you Factor bow set in October
inappropriate
excuse me bow set you can look at the
door because I only want woody I only
want Woody's would bow set your ugly I
don't care where she sends nudes but you
wanted spooky memes when she sends nudes
but she doesn't send her skeleton I hate
it disgusting
does she not get it all right bad Peppa
the pig never got a pig oh oh my dog
Peppa the pig has four eyes if you think
about it okay that is actually genuinely
terrifying what in the actual
than your parent ask where all your
skin's and muscle and organs when I
don't know it's spooky month mom don't
you get it white boy black boy Asian boy
gay boy straight boy boys I think
spooking isn't cool huh have you thought
of this video to prove that you think
it's cool yet oh damn
yeah
lane lamp everybody
YouTube has just YouTube really the
internet has been taken over by lambs
and moths it's a love story well-fitting
of spooky money meme review everybody oh
wait I forgot new merge mean review
official merch everybody it doesn't get
any better than this
alright and well fitted for the spooky
move clap clap
do you think you have what it takes mean
review everybody we also have a hat that
says police be patient I'm nine years
old so people will know now where was I
that's right Mothe memes hi um let me
get a large lamb
can someone please give him off lamb I
think it's only fair it's a love story
it's a romance better than Twilight like
I want you like ma we cannot be together
this window was only a temporary
obstacle like it's not that then what is
it the power is going down
[Music]
let me go ma do not give up everyone
I didn't think I would cry again on
camera last time I was walking dead her
he's probably thinking about other girls
him lamb lamb are the Lambs ready
brother this meme started off from a
reddit post which showed this horrific
woof I'm sorry to call him that close-up
of MA outside my window Jesus Christ but
it also shows an expression a side of
moth that we haven't seen before
a humanizing of the mob usually I see
him off and I just want to kill it now I
see him off and I go that's a sexy ma oh
I'm sorry are we are we going to pretend
that we're not attracted to moth all
decided have you seen this huh don't
tell me you wouldn't smash that not come
in star to you how about this image
getting turned on by this image preteen
boys on the Internet 2010 and ma you're
lying you're lying to yourself if you
don't think moths are attractive don't
look at me like that you faster powerset
didn't you you weirdo
you see you just add the math to the
mock it'll make sense big titty girl
what do you think lamps are effing six
change my mind you can't you just can't
hey look it's this meme again making its
fourth out four hundred millionth
appearance do you want anything from
Ikea lamp just give me a lamp that's all
I want
I can't hold on give me your hand first
give me the lamp that is so clever when
you found out Paris is the city of
lights what is this 2012 2012 memes when
you found out there are oil lamps hey
hey hey this is totally me guys this is
so relatable me and review Hey look
by the merge okay guys Yaga mean light
yeah get it cuz his name is light in
there it's probably too complex for you
the maka means really are very complex
moth god I wish there were me for mas
they just want lamb and that's it one
day I'm going to be a beautiful
butterfly
several poor life decisions later lamb
[Music]
sannasmom fairness mob that's incredible
I like I'm off the Mach means is sort of
a weird Ugandan lamp and brother brother
as a certain way of articulating itself
it's a reminiscent to say the least of
better types and lo may i acquire the
land
[Music]
damn time
oh yeah I fill it there's on what the
temperatures play laughs my gosh why for
free Honda EU 2 2 0 0 hi 2200 like 120
volt super quiet portable inverter
generator moths lamp moths lamp
everybody smash like on the video and
give and I mean by the vs. enough of
that
go away damn you well you're going to
get it now
lamb-lamb lamp a brother so I've been
trying to figure out this mean but I
don't get it like where's the punch
20:18 memes are just so confusing lamps
and smooth slabs top of lamp lamp saves
me slaps top of lamp again
slap double abrogate slat I like this
one it's clever it's very good
touching lamp because lamp is good dying
because lamp is hot
perfectly balanced as all things should
be the math meme
gets extra 5 points for being disgusting
extra 10 points for me mouki in smoke
tober mmm an extra - five points for I
don't know no reason and the result is
7.5 everybody wow that's really good
congratulations mock me you scored very
high on the mean review chart
hopefully you'll live a couple more days
the last means of this week it's the
tick tock bad guys now I can't show the
actual audio because they'll disclaim
all the revenue on the video and if I
can't make money off of memes then
what's the point why would I even bother
doing it so instead you'll get the
copyright free PewDiePie it singing
version of this meat map feel free to
use this if you ever want to review it
as well why do good girls only like that
guy said this question for a real long
time right bad 40s going to see you know
musically dying but it's just like any
other cancer it comes back in a
different form
we were so happy we were celebrating
music Holly is gone did good dirty did
it did but no it came back and it came
back stronger than ever with tick tock
so now not just kids are posting actual
adults are posting these memes where
they transform from this really good guy
to this really cool bad guy with this
creme G song in the background I don't
know what it is but it goes like you
either go girl
this resevoir a long time little bed for
yet plain to see the wider world where
love with me
what in the actual the thing is like
there's so many cringy ones that I can't
tell which ones are joking or not
[Laughter]
goddamn add this meme gets my 10 points
for having copyrighted okay stop using
music and your memes please I guess
another - I don't know I don't like it
it gets a zero okay zero
that's right oh that's it up that's all
the time we have for this week's main
review everybody you to go check out the
merch link in the description thank you
guys so much for supporting this show I
really appreciate it and I see you guys
next time
epic bro face